we'd go over these really awesome
exciting tantalizing new results
that i started hearing about uh just a
couple of days ago we're talking to
professor constantine batigen
as am i pronouncing your name correctly
constantine it's a
it's a good approximation uh you know
it's it's
good enough for astrophysics i i
i don't speak i speak three fewer
languages than you
i know you speak three languages that's
like this like
negative five languages
well it is great to meet you i know
you're
legends you're you're uh very extremely
accomplished and you're in the small
technical college i believe uh
caltech up north in los angeles yeah
that's right
what are you going to say oh no i just
said we're accredited we just passed
accreditation
when i was there the football team would
regularly lose to junior varsity high
school football teams but that's not why
people go to caltech
and i think that they've gotten better
and we're joined with a nice crowd on
youtube as well
and that is for good reason because
constantine
has some fantastic new results about a
planet
that shall be called number nine
uh revolutionary as the beatles would
say revolution number nine planet number
nine now first of all i thought there
was a planet number nine i
i was talking this week with neil
degrasse tyson uh
who you know at one point claimed uh
that that there that pluto was not the
ninth planet
so what's the current status where do
you come down on this eternal
battle is pluto a planet is pluto not a
planet
i mean you know i like
i just i don't care that much you know
what
that's like i'm pretty orthogonal to the
whole
debate my viewpoint on all these things
is that um you know it's got a mass
it's got a radius you know it's got real
physical quantities
uh that that you can really talk about
and and kind of
that are actually interesting pluto
actually geologically is very
interesting as well that said like does
it
you know if i was to choose does it
arise up to the
kind of concept of a planet of i mean my
sense is of course not
right pluto is uh
rather unaware of its own work right i
mean i i
tend to think about planets as things
that are
uh that are sufficient gravitational
drivers
in the dynamics of a planetary system
where if you remove it
something changes dramatically right if
you remove pluto
nothing will change and in any case the
story of how pluto acquired
its planetary status is a really
remarkable one
right pluto was initially
mistaken for the seven earth mass
planet x that uh that was predicted at
the time
and upon its discovery uh its mass was
revised downwards to one earth mass of
course
nobody could uh nobody really knew how
to measure
mass uh you need a satellite and when
saddle when k-ron was discovered in 1978
it was like whoa you know this thing is
you know
really quite uh quite tiny so so yeah
it's a really
uh i think much more interesting than
the question of definition about what is
a plan what is not is actually the
historical
arc right the uh the parseval lol
story of of looking for planet x is a
fascinating
uh piece of kind of astronomical history
and
and how that linked to the discovery of
pluto is really
phenomenal yeah all the uh all the
planets
at least beyond the no ones known since
antiquity
i think i heard that galileo
accidentally
could have discovered here's galileo
constantine someday you'll have a sock
puppet too a finger puppet too but this
is galileo
the first mariner of the skies using
telescopic
aid and he had some success with
observing planets as you know with
jupiter and saturn he thought
and he actually encrypted his findings
you you may
be able to explain this better than me
but he would write you know in
in like backwards handwriting and and he
would write in in like
rhymes and limericks one of them was the
um
the fifth planet an altitude is
threefold and that was of course he
couldn't resolve the rings of saturn
nowadays
it seems like people wouldn't sit on a
discovery of planet nine so
are you are you are you burying the news
are you hiding obfuscating that you've
seen planet nine
or what are we looking at with this
fantastic new paper that i'll show on
this
right it's all an anagram right if you
just
no no no uh so so we of course you know
it would be a an immediate
uh it would be an immediate announcement
the moment
we or i think anybody else for that
matter discovers
planet nine but the observational search
for planet nine has generically been
going horribly and this is not because
uh
you know we've collected zero data it's
been horribly because
of course when you when you're looking
for one object it is going horribly
until you discover it and then it's
going great
right so um you know in parallel
with the kind of observational arc of
of looking for planet nine we're always
pushing
the theoretical framework forward and
this is kind of
the latest in our
you know in our program to make
the planet nine models maximally
realistic
we spent uh some time about three four
years ago actually
going the opposite way developing models
that are
maximally simplistic to get an
analytical
handle on the on the dynamics understand
it better
um but here we are doing the opposite we
we have decided to go and
basically look at you know the state of
the art that we had
from a couple years ago okay what what
is missing
right what is missing from the theory
as it stands right now and the answer
here is simple to summarize we
uh often in our models treat
uh and this is not just us like
everybody does this
right everybody if you're worried about
the solar system you treat the solar
system as the entirety of the universe
right as far as your simulation is
concerned
right you've got the sun at the center
and you draw a sphere of you know
whatever
ten thousand twenty thousand a you uh
around it and things that leave
that sphere are just deleted from the
simulations and
never heard from again um and you know
importantly nothing ever comes into that
sphere either
that's not really true right the solar
system did not form in isolation
it formed in a cluster of stars just
like
most stars do and uh so we decided to
really
take a closer look at this um what are
the consequences
of properly modeling the early evolution
of of the solar system and the answer is
that um
early in its sort of during the first
few million years of
the sun's evolution in its birth cluster
uh
jupiter and saturn form eject a bunch of
material but some of that material gets
trapped in a quasi-spherical cloud
around the sun uh what we now call the
inner oort cloud
and if planet nine is not there it's not
really a big deal the inner
ward cloud just sits there forever but
if planet nine
is there and i i think it is uh
then its gravity acts to reinject some
of that material back
into the distant kuiper
oh belt about that hi guys
uh clubhouse re we got people on
clubhouse we're talking about planet
nine
maybe catherine i'll make you a
moderator can you change the name or no
is that impossible
all right we're talking planet nine so
i'll take questions for
uh professor constantine bategian of
caltech later on but it's a fascinating
discovery uh that is being announced
we're talking about the impact of
uh of objects beyond the kuiper belt
right we're talking about
kuiper belt or beyond kuiper belt
objects uh constantine yeah these
these are really things beyond the
kuiper belt i mean these are
i mean to give some scale some sense of
scale right neptune's at
30 astronomical units meaning it's 30
times as far away from the sun as
is the earth um you know
pluto's at 40 roughly speaking um
the objects that inform
from which we infer the existence of
planet nine these are things
that are hundreds of a.u right hundreds
of times as far away from the
sun as as the earth we're now talking
about re-injecting
things back into the solar system from
thousands right
this is not quite flirting with the
um re the conventional oort cloud
like where oort cloud comets come from
because that's yet another order of
magnitude
uh further out that's you know twenty
thousand fifty thousand that you that's
kind of old right
starting to flirt with you know quarter
of the way to the next star
um this is still you know closer in but
as it turns out if planet nine is there
inner oort cloud material gets
re-injected
into the outer solar system and mixes in
with the kuiper belt
now that pollution of the distant kuiper
belt by
this oort cloud material is something we
hadn't really
ever modeled before and when we account
for this
effect in new uh in these new models
planet nine
uh becomes somewhat more eccentric the
best fit planet nine becomes marginally
more eccentric
which is important for the observational
search after all
if something is a little bit more
eccentric it's aphelion is a little bit
further away
the thing is a little dimmer i don't
actually expect this to
change our observational strategy by by
a long shot by a new account but
uh but this does contribute uh to
kind of the limits that we place with
the observational search
i had uh professor avi loeb on the
podcast talking about his
controversial theory of omua as
originating as an extra
solar piece of technology not just from
from a solar system formation in its own
kuiper belt or its own oort cloud
um how polluted or how how full of
traffic
is the kuiper belt is it like los
angeles right about now
or or is it uh you know contrary to the
impression of it kind of being
jam-packed with debris and icebergs and
so forth
how how dense in population is the oort
cloud
and kuiper belt rather yeah i mean if i
was
i don't know i think the better the
better analogy than
los angeles now would be like
middle of new mexico
during covet when nobody is tr nobody's
driving
i mean it is it is astonishing actually
how
uh despite there being
you know whatever number of objects
there are
the space between them is huge now the
question that you can
immediately ask so like that i guess
where i'm going with this is
the kuiper belt at the scale of objects
that we usually care about
right so things that are you know 100
kilometers across
or 10 kilometers across it's completely
collisionless right those particles will
never
come into contact with one another
they'll never see
one another it's cumulative gravity is
negligible
as far as the question of you know what
about
the amount of material that gets
injected
into the kuiper belt through from the
oort cloud
there we can actually make an estimate
and i think
it's on the order of a percent of an
earth mass over the age of the solar
system you might say well that's not
that doesn't sound like very much but
the kuiper belt itself
is about one percent of an earth mass
cumulatively
so you know it's it's kind of uh it's a
competing mass scale
for um or if you were to to kind of
compare bonafide you know kuiper belt
objects that are that are real
you know things that have been scattered
out by neptune
and things that have been reinjected
back if i'm not mistaken kuiper
jared or gerald uh kuiper he actually
postulated it
and not in the context of early solar
system dynamics but
really is a form of dark matter is it
was not correct that there was some
connection between the kuiper belt and a
proposed
resolution of the dark matter conundrum
that most of the matter we see
via its gravitational effects is
non-luminous and non-interacting and
it's thought that this kuiper belt could
provide some of that but as you're
saying it's
incredibly low density right it's
totally insufficient
yeah it's pathetic right hyperbole is
pathetic
i scoff every time i think about the
kuiper belt
what about the oort cloud is the oort
cloud anymore uh you know of a force to
be reckoned with
a little bit yeah so the what's
interesting is at least for the kuiper
belt we have
measures of mass that that are dynamic
like
you can use telemetry of spacecraft to
put
limits on the amount of mass out there
and that's kind of where you get the
sort of
one percent of an earth mass or
something like that with
um the classical oort cloud our
understanding
comes from you know here comes a comet
with a period of a hundred thousand
years
let's now estimate how many there are in
total
and so if you do the numbers you get
about five earth masses in total but
if it was 0.5 you you could still make
the numbers worth so there's sort of an
order of magnitude uncertainty but the
best uh
the best fit number for the classical
oort cloud is
you know five earth masses the inner
oort cloud a little bit less
now if there were to suddenly be you
know someone who's even more
um vehemently opposed to the kuiper belt
and even the oort cloud
and this uh omnipotent being completely
vaporizes and and annihilates all the
material of the kuiper belt
and the oort cloud would we ever have
any effect here on earth would it make
life safer on earth and avoid
the cometary disaster that befell the
dinosaurs some 66 million years ago
yeah um so great question you know for
the
this actually ties beautifully into
the story of how the kuiper belt was
postulated in the first place which is
different from what kuiper said
if you read kuiper's actual original
paper
it's very speculative it's kind of like
i'm not
saying there's a kuiper belt saying like
maybe there might be one i don't know i
don't know
you never know uh that's kind of the
effect the extent
of uh certainty but in the 80s
um as computers became faster and people
like martin duncan
started doing simulations of in fact the
very question that you're asking about
the
cometary flux um you know
it became clear that the solar system
would run out of jupiter family comets
on a time scale much shorter than the
age of the solar system so the fact that
we have
a cometary flux you know which
where it looks like it's coming from
jupiter means that jupiter itself
is sourcing comets from some more
further away
and these are things that come from
indeed the kuiper belt particularly the
scattered disc population of the kuiper
belt
um is one where neptune will
occasionally just
scatter things out of the solar system
and they're gone forever or
will scatter things inwards and then the
giant planets sort of play soccer with
these
uh you know pieces of debris until they
reach jupiter's orbit and once they
uh once jupiter injects the material
into the inner solar system
we see you know activation of coal we
see real
real comments that we then uh
oftentimes refer to as jupiter family
comets but they're really sourced from
the kaikoura so
if we destroy the kuiper belt uh we will
remove one source of commentary
bombardment if we destroy the oort cloud
we will just
you know remove another source of
commentary bombardment we'll remove the
oort cloud comments um but will we
remove
all impacts no no of course not
because uh many of them are
actually in fact sourced from the
asteroid belt right the asteroids due to
radiative effects drift into resonances
with jupiter
uh get into the kirkwood gaps basically
get their eccentricities excited until
they cross mars and then mars shoots
them onto earth so meteorites follow
this chaotic route
uh to the earth's orbit um
so as much as i would i think it's a
good idea to destroy the kuiper belt it
won't make
the you know life safe for us
so we're talking to professor
constantine bategian
who as is as hilarious as he is
brilliant you may have seen him as i did
first on 60 minutes what was that five
six years ago you're working
with mike brown and uh bill whitaker i
remember poking around i'm that was
about
2017 2016. it feels like it was about
59 minutes ago i mean really
it's uh it's amazing how rapidly time
passes particularly
you know like everybody knows about time
dilation due to gravity but time
dilation due to covet is really profound
yeah so kids too you're you're a father
and
you must know that the longest period of
time is the time between dinner time and
bedtime for any child or any parent
uh has to endure that is where time
dilation really kicks in doesn't it
exactly exactly yeah
well we're all doing our best so back in
uh january i mean at that time in 2016
we were uh
i became aware of you from work that you
did with mike brown who is the pluto
killer he was your thesis advisor right
yeah back in the day back in the day
yeah back in the day it's
again you know i i now teach uh
some of the classes i took uh as a grad
student
and i just you know i used to take great
kind of like you know kind of you know
in a tongue-in-cheek way
talk about how when i took this class
you know everything was different
but these days it's like when i took
this class really everything was
different
all right just a few years ago
yeah unbelievable that's right yeah
so uh in that paper in that time you
were talking about
sedna and sedna like what the heck is
said no what happened to it
how come i don't hear about it was it
just one of these flash in the pan
hollywood you know
flings that that come and go like uh
like a comment in the word cloud
what is sadness it's still there and
what's a sedna like object
it's 100 percent it's definitely still
there i'm feeling it's gravity well i'm
not really feeling it's gravity
i'm feeling its quintessence right now
uh
yeah look sedna it was a huge discovery
at the time it was the first uh
truly clear indication that the solar
system is not done
right that there's something really
remarkable that's going to be
uh that's that's hiding beyond the
observational
uh frontier even of the kuiper belt
itself
um now the kuiper belt when it started
getting mapped out
people were very excited about all of
the dynamical structure that it exhibits
that study helped that kind of
collective study helped
you know really rewrite the story about
how the solar system
evolved in its first 10 to 100 million
years but
sedna was something different altogether
so when mike
and company this uh discovered it i
guess back in 2003 or 2004
i actually remember hearing about it um
i was in high school at the time but
this
uh this dude in my like history class
was like
bro they found planet eggs um
so um yeah so
yeah so so what's weird about sedna is
that
while the vast majority of kyber belt
objects
are easy to understand with the current
markup
of the planets that that we know and
love
uh sedna never really interacts with
anything right it's
it's perihelion it's closest approach to
the sun
is more than twice as far away from the
sun as
is neptune so it never directly it never
really sees
neptune's you know it never seems
neptune as a individual particle if you
will it only sees the kind of
orbit average quadrupole potential of
neptune or anybody else for that matter
so it just kind of sits there
now if you see that you might say okay
that's kind of weird and the reason it's
weird is that
vast majority of long period orbits
were scattered out by neptune but
if this gets scattered out by neptune
because gravity is conservative they
always have to come back to where they
started from
so all of these objects are just kind of
tethered to neptune sedna
is not it was the first tip of the
iceberg
of a population of bodies that
look like they've been pulled away from
from the giant planets and are now uh
just sort of
doing their own thing now
the entire planet nine story was
constructed
from you know what at least one of the
original arguments was
to say look if you look at the distant
solar system there is clustering
what we see now in the current data set
which really quite
in my opinion profound is that the
clustering
is much stronger among these objects
that have been strongly pulled away from
neptune these detached
kuiper belt objects um the objects that
are attached to neptune are kind of
all over the place and uh
to give ourselves just a little bit of
credit
uh even back in 2016 we wrote about this
in the
in the first paper about how only the
dynamically stable objects
uh should cluster and the fact that
that's kind of
been you know reflected in the data is
pretty
is pretty exciting of course it's no you
know it's not
like reason to you know call
call the game and say we're done but
it's it's certainly going into the right
direction yeah it's fascinating and i
want to point out you know what you do
um do you think of yours how do you
think of yourself uh besides being a
father husband
musician you know uh world famous 60
minutes superstar
how do you uh think of yourself are you
uh should people think of you as a guy
with a telescope you know looking out at
the sky
or or is it a scientist looking into a
computer
what do you focus mostly on because the
paper i'm showing on the screen
is a lot of you know it looks like a lot
of spirograph activity going on over
here
so to what extent can we have confidence
in in the existence of this object
if you're not seeing it through a
telescope uh
yeah that's a great question and look uh
i actually
think this is a this hits on an
important
uh topic because oftentimes the planet
nine story
kind of gets over amplified both ways
right uh there's kind of there's a some
pleasure in
kind of proclaiming that planet nine is
just
oh my god it's so there it's just you
know it's gonna be
any minute now or you know or like
planet nine is dead
right nine really is
in some sense uh you know a little bit
like schrodinger's cat where where it
has a wave function of
being of being in existence until we
we measure it and that
um that probability really hinges
on uh on a few different things it
hinges on
how certain are we that the
first of all how certain are we on that
the
patterns that we see in the in the
distant solar system
really are you know there now you can
that this has been a subject of of some
debate
okay in the last uh you know few months
including um
but you know the way there's and there's
indeed multiple ways to do
the uh the statistical analysis um
the kind of analysis that we've done
suggests a false alarm probability of
sort of
one of one and five hundred right that
kind of point two percent
um the the other thing that i should
note
is in all of these models
all that really happens at the end of
the days all that we can say
is that there is some external gravity
and so we can assign a mass and an orbit
to to
you know the external perturber right
whether like the fact that this is a
planet is just us making it up
right we we think that a planet is the
most reasonable
source of a five earth mass object on uh
on such a gravity but in principle the
orbits would
the calculations would work as well if
this was a five earth mass burrito
or you know a five earth mass tissue
like
just really anything that has five earth
mass uh you know that orbits on the
right orbit would do the job
um now finally to answer your question
about you know
what whether or not i use a telescope um
you know i've gotten involved with
observations
uh as part of this project because you
know
that's that's been something uh
that you know i've been sort of had the
pleasure of
uh of doing together with mike mike is a
real ninja
at the telescope uh right he's truly
truly phenomenal but um you know
predominantly
i kind of lead the theoretical side of
the planet nine project whereas he leads
the more observational
uh side of the project so um
the we've we've over the years diffused
our duties uh quite a bit
but uh but you know that that that
division is still
to an extent there um i also i'll be
honest i
i really enjoy theory a lot more i find
a real thrill in doing theoretical work
um that i i just don't maybe resonate
with as much
when we're at the telescope and staying
up all night
and not drinking you know staying up all
night and
at a party is way more fun than staying
up all night on a telescope
or performing in your in your band
what's the name of your band
the name of the band is the seventh
season we
we're gonna have uh you know we're going
to be
um yeah the we we're already kind of
like the
the most overrated band even though
there is no
uh critical acclaim uh but it's gonna be
even more true in the coming in the
coming months
i can't wait i hope to see catch you
guys live and
maybe i'll get a guitar pick thrown my
way the last thing i want to say
about what you do on your daily basis
revolves around
you know this notion that oh planets in
the solar system it's kind of
old hat newton solved everything if it
doesn't involve einstein or schrodinger
who cares it's not really cutting edge
talk about the
tools that you do use the simulations
the super computer talk about the tools
that you use
and where we're going technologically to
hopefully unravel the mystery and the
existence of it and maybe even observe
it directly or
maybe buy a spacecraft or something yeah
you know
i'm so glad you brought this up because
this was my perspective
as well before i got involved with solar
system research
um and i think it ties in very
nicely with the with the common
misconception that
20th century physics and 21st century
physics
it's basically just two things like it's
either gr
or you know or or quantum mechanics
in some advanced or like particle
physics um
you know one of the i think one of the
coolest
advances that unfolded at the end of the
20th century was really
chaos theory coming into its own
and becoming a big part of
of natural science as it turns out the
solar system is one of the best
laboratories where where long-term chaos
manifests so and planet nine
is a and planet in the outer solar
system itself
is not only not immune from chaotic
dynamics
all of this story is chaotic dynamics
right so when we are doing these
simulations
we're not you know setting mv squared
over
r equal to g m m over r squared and
canceling the m's and one of the r's
right
i mean this this involves doing
uh long-term simulations that are that
are based on syntactic maps uh which
basically only give you a statistical
estimate at the end of the day of
what types of dynamical evolution planet
nine
can instill because each
you know each trajectory is just some uh
like chaotic uh you know whisper if you
will of all
of some chaotic sampling of of the
different dynamical modes so
um at the end of the day you have to go
if you're
for this problem especially you have to
go to the super computer
um and at times just to just
basically have enough realizations of
the model to
uh really understand what's going on
so uh yeah it's it's just it's a
remarkably
um advanced you know and really
intriguing field now when it comes to
observations themselves
right that's a field where um you know
the recent advances in machine learning
have played a huge
you know role as well right i mean the
way that
the way you do image analysis these days
is not clyde tombow style where you're
trying to blink a couple images and
note something that moved it's it's ai
doing that for you
and it's and all of these advances truly
have been interlinked
so we're getting some questions this
reminder we're talking with professor
constantine
batigen of california institute of
technology a small
technical college on the outskirts of
northern los angeles
county and uh we're discussing some of
the implications of new
simulations the new paper that came out
just yesterday i think
it was embargoed uh and uh and i got to
really lucky break to get ahold of
constantine through various means and
modalities of communication but we're
talking about
these really massive simulations and the
tools and techniques
of a theoretical planetary scientist a a
a person who's working at the boundaries
of
what technology can do now and people
are asking questions which i think you
know you you
essentially answered but you don't know
what this object could be it could be
someone's asking could it be a
black hole a primordial black hole
somehow lurking on the outskirts of the
solar system and actually none none
other than edward whitton
has proposed such uh possibilities maybe
not for planet nine specifically
or for this object specifically but that
there may be the opera
the possibility of a black hole so you
may
actually get constantine you may
actually get to have a brush with black
holes and
gr and all sorts of things that that
people would assume you might envy but
yeah can you say something about that is
there
is there much uh excitement about that
or is that kind of just a fanciful
notion that
isn't real well look i mean so like i
said we don't know
what it is it could be anything as long
as it's five earth masses a primordial
black hole
of course you know comes in a whole
spectrum of of
masses uh as as you know uh very well
so that's that's one possibility this
has been pointed out in the literature
not by us but uh by unwin
and and schultz i believe or or maybe
i'm getting the authors
uh reversed but uh yeah this has been
this is one uh you know idea
that's out there what's what's really
remarkable
here is is just how different
at the detailed level this whole
calculation is from the one of neptune
right neptune was discovered by
seeing the gravitational effect it had
on uranus
and deriving its existence that way
in the case of neptune all you could
really derive
was it's it's on sky location and kind
of the immediate
on sky path because uranus and neptune
were a conjunction in 1846 when le
verrier was doing the calculation so
uh in fact la verrier and adams both got
the
orbits of neptune and the mass of
neptune wrong but they got on sky
location right
the planet nine story is the polar
opposite of that you can
you actually can calculate the mass of
the
um and orbit with some
you know reasonable degree of of
certainty
but one thing you cannot know is where
it is on its orbit and what it is
yeah actually dan green is a colleague
of mine here at ucsd
uh was commenting on twitter yesterday
he was actually in clubhouse
a few minutes ago about uh these notions
like the what the greatness of
einstein was is that he had to accept
things like
uh you know relativity but then
overthrow it in favor of
you know giving up the notion of
simultaneity uh
and and instead focusing on things like
the invariant interval
uh but whereas la verrier i think that's
how you said his name right uh
he proposed he discovered uh neptune
based on the
uh the the perturbations to uranus's
orbit but then he tried to do something
and predict uh the aberrations of
mercury based on the existence of vulcan
you want to talk a little bit about
how a brilliant scientist can get things
spectacularly right
and then try to use that same technology
same tool
and get things you know blunderingly
wrong
yeah absolutely i mean so mercury the
transits of mercury
uh the measurements of transits of
mercury became
quite precise by the mid-1800s so
uh um you know in parallel with the
advancements of celestial mechanics at
the time
it became clear that the orbit of
mercury is processing right in a
rotating
somewhat faster and that's 43 arc
seconds per century faster
than would be predicted by
by the newtonian law of gravity
so there are two ways to resolve this
problem
one is modifying the law of gravity
right that's
uh that's certainly one way which of
course
ended up to be the correct answer and
the other one is to
is to fix it the way you fix it is you
put a planet
close to the surface of the sun such
that
the sun basically becomes effectively
oblate
that can give you a degree of procession
that that can advance mercury's
perihelion by the right amount
that was levirie's uh
prediction of course it turned out to be
wrong but
you know to give it to give leverier
full credit
right that mystery like recognizing that
mystery and solving that mystery and
uh was was part of that part of the
pyramid really that led to
the success of uh
you know of relativity because i think
by by 1915
it had become somewhat clear that um
planet vulcan was really not there so so
this
mystery was really amplified by uh by
leveria's work
all right yeah reminder we're talking to
uh professor
constantine batigen earlier this week we
talked to neil degrasse tyson and in the
past i've talked to avi loeb
and sarah seeger and you know it would
be really dereliction of my duty as a as
a youtube uh
creator as we called as we discussed
earlier today
if i didn't ask you about these three
people tyson
uh and and also avi loeb and also
sarah seeger whose episode will come out
hopefully in the next couple of weeks
um [ __ ] let's work backwards sarah
seeger and and collaborators have a
proposal that there might be
an uh uh life um evidentiary
piece of uh molecule molecular phosphine
which can be indicative of a biological
process
operating on the clouds of venus so
first of all
what how do you react to that um what do
you make of that uh i know it's not your
field and it's dangerous but as a
even as a lay person if you want what
how do you react to that what are your
thoughts on that particular
controversial new discovery
uh so my my understanding of this
uh and again i only follow i've only
followed
that the phosphine story kind of
uh peripherally um
now my understanding was that when that
crime
story came out right there was an
immediate kind of outcry about how the
data
you know can be fit in a different way
and and that's a really important
uh you know it's really important to be
skeptical for for discoveries
like these because they're they're so uh
monumental
and so the pendulum kind of swung into
the
phosphine is not there but my
understanding was that a recent
reanalysis of some older data actually
looks you know somewhat more favorable
again my
i'm not an expert in in phosphine in any
case
my my overall sense is that life
is just a contaminant on an otherwise
interesting planetary surface
but um you know it's it's one of these
things where
where it's it's really quite exciting
that uh such work
is being carried out and at the end of
the day it's
you know if if there is a hint in the
data if something
interesting is going on it's it's always
of course worthwhile
to you know to ask the question can what
are the pathways to produce
uh this molecule naturally right what
are the geological pathways to do this
and you know are the geological pathways
reasonable if they are
if there are none or if they are you
know
if they require assumptions that are not
uh you know
not particularly i should say um
not particularly realistic then you know
you you go to life as a
as an alternative hypothesis it's
it's interesting stuff right yeah big
stuff
yeah and then uh next going you know
reverse chronologically
i had uh i had avilaban and he has this
theory which
uh which is that not only is there life
in the galaxy
but there's technological life and
advanced technological life that can
send
a solar sail powered uh spacecraft
to our solar system for purposes we
don't know
uh but this is uh his contention at very
high confidence level of
it not being a fluke in other words the
confidence that he ascribes to it is
over 90
which is not you know they're going to
call up stockholm as the joke goes you
know
with three sigma they'll invite you to
give a seminar but they won't pay you
back
you know at five sigma they'll pay for
your your hotel for one night and then
seven sigma they'll take you to
stockholm
uh to win one of these things which you
know maybe someday you'll you'll have on
around your neck but but let me ask you
constantly what do you make of avi
loeb's theory not not him personally but
but the theory itself on its own merits
well actually i know avi really well uh
i would my office was
when i was a postdoc my office was
across the hall
from uh from obvious so uh you know uh
avi of course has a a remarkable
amount of you know a remarkable amount
of energy
and uh you know i remember he he ran
into
my office at one point and said you know
i have
figured this out like i was i was
you know whatever cooking i think he was
saying that
either he was cooking thanksgiving
dinner was he was helping his wife cook
it thanksgiving dinner he's like i
figured out that at one point the entire
universe
was room temperature i mean
of course it was right he's like imagine
it
like imagine living in in that universe
just
everything is habitable just everything
you go outside
it's just it's just room temperature man
like
you know it's just nice it's like i
don't know
it's like the south of france in you
know in april
right just uh so you know avi has
has cool ideas i i think you know my i
personally
ascribe to on
the you know the notion that life really
should be
a a hypothesis of
last resort because it's one to which
uh it's one that kind of opens up a huge
can of warmth
let me also say one more thing the
question of
whether or not there is life elsewhere
in
the galaxy for example is a completely
boring question
okay of course there's life elsewhere in
the galaxy
right we at this point know that
extrasolar planets are super common
right there's just there's in my
view a negligible amount of probability
okay ascribe to the notion that somehow
the earth
is a unique uh spot
in in all of cosmos where where life uh
emerged and everywhere else it didn't
right the question of whether or not
it's there
i think is is one that's answered it's
there
the real interesting question is where's
the closest life
you know where's the closest life is it
uh in the
icy satellites um and to give credit
where it's due
uh this is this was something you know i
i changed my entire thinking of this
as a consequence of conversation with
mike you know mike brown because he was
uh the one who pointed this out to me
and i thought it made a lot of sense
right like
you know is it europa are the oceans of
europa teeming with life or do we have
to travel
you know 100 parsecs before we uh
encounter the first uh the first life
form now with the question of
is of course an interesting one but
let's not forget that the
entire story there is coming
like all of this excitement is coming
from a
question a measurement of you know a
light curve
which goes up and down stochastically
and
non-gravitational acceleration right so
that's where the all that's
that's the foundation of all of that
debate i think it's
it's important to keep to keep that in
mind right i think
uh it one way or another we'll learn a
lot more with
lsst coming online soon yeah absolutely
so we're going to finish up in the next
few minutes so
we can get some some alcohol into
constantine he's had a busy week he
deserves it but there's a very important
question
coming in from christian ready whose
show you should go on
called launch pad astronomy my good
friend christian
is asking a very important question what
kind of bass guitar
is behind you ah yeah that so
that's an ibanez uh that's an ibanez
in fact that one is not mine it's uh
from the base player
in in the band um you know he he
made the mistake of leaving it in my
office
um and then covet happened so i've i've
appropriated it
pandemic base yeah that's right this is
my pandemic base because my base
is in um you know it's locked away
in a room that i have no longer i can't
get into as long as there's coven so
uh yeah well you'll have to wait to play
the music of the spheres
uh as kovit is on the wane hopefully
things will
uh lighten up there in los angeles and
pasadena my old stomping grounds
uh last couple of last question for me
before we turn it to the audience
there's a bunch of people
over 110 on youtube ask people to
subscribe
and leave a comment if you'd like to see
more like this and you'd like to see
more of constantine
you can find him on the web at his name
constantine batigen it's a little bit
hard but i put it up there his twitter
is k batigen
and it's b-a-t-y-g-i-n and uh not too
many people have a
name of my favorite alcohol in their
name but constantine certainly does
uh so constantine i want to know where
are we going in this field is it going
to take
machine learning artificial intelligence
you know what what's the next direction
as a
non-telescopic astronomer where do you
what are you most excited about
um coming in more data you mentioned the
reuben observatory lsst
what are you most excited about as the
next technological or
scientific breakthrough in your specific
field yeah okay so for the solar system
for the outer solar system
of course vera rubin is it
uh not meaning that's the only thing but
it's you know going to be a huge
revolution
for uh i spend quite a bit of time uh
doing work on extrasolar planets
right that's a field that's very healthy
and it's kind of continues to
um you know gain gain traction
i think that's another uh there you know
things like james webb coming online uh
as well as
a whole range really of of missions
menu of space telescopes many of them in
europe like plato
you know coming online and providing uh
swaths of new data the generic story
with exoplanets
is that they keep you know of course
surprising us
right there's stuff time after time uh
you know they keep disproving what we
thought was right about planet formation
which is great right planet formation is
not a field
uh it's not a theory with a lot of
predictive power it only kind of has
retroaddictive power
um and finally you know i've
i've recently gotten involved in and
trying to understand how the satellites
form the galilean satellites because as
you mentioned galileo found them
about four centuries ago to this day we
don't actually
know very well how uh how they formed
like the basic
question of why they are there is is an
exciting one and it's going to only get
more exciting in the next
decade because there's things like
europa clipper going to europa
there's a dragonfly flying to titan
which is the biggest moon of saturn
there's an isa mission called juice
which is going to go and study ganymede
which is the most massive satellite of
jupiter in excruciating detail
so whenever you have uh
stuff like this happen right more better
telescopes
direct you know missions that
tell you something about the geo the
geophysics of
uh you know these bodies it always
brings together a wealth of new data
which crushes
the old models and allows people like me
to get
you know excited and construct new
models so
i um yeah i really really
am looking forward sort of uh to the
next
decade and i'm really i'm not like
sitting around
hoping you know more data comes in i'm
just i'm excited about
where planetary astronomy broadly
speaking is going to be
over the next 10 20 years yeah we have a
question well it's sort of the
modification of stuart brands is saying
cosmology which is what i do is a
massive distraction and it's a drain on
resources
i'm going to turn that around he's a
little bit grouchy here
stewart come on don't don't threaten my
livelihood here my friend
but i will ask the question would you
take a one-way trip
to mars as uh upcoming guest andy weir
who's coming on the end of the
impossible podcast very soon
wrote about in the martian it almost
happened to uh the astronaut watley
uh i i want to know would you take a
trip to another planet
to sedna to planet nine uh what
what would you what would you most want
to see up close and put your astronaut
boots on to it
absolutely not just absolutely not yeah
i mean i i have
very well formed opinions about this
like
i love the planets uh
mars i don't love as much uh as the
other ones
uh but like you know i love doing what i
do
but i have absolutely no interest about
leaving earth and furthermore i think
you know it's important to not
have delusions about uh the earth
not being awesome the earth is the the
only home as
like i really feel this way you know
we evolved on on this planet we have uh
millions of years of evolution which
cannot be uh which cannot be
kind of undone
in a um just because we
we wish to explore now planet space
exploration is obviously
super important and i think having a
manned mission to mars i think there
will be one
kind of in in our lifetime all of that
you know
is is worthwhile etc etc but
i have i think you know uh
if we're talking about dedication of
resources et cetera et cetera
um you know i i view climate change and
generically the
destruction of ecosystem on earth as a
far
more important uh problem
than than any of this i think i don't
think that we are
going to be able to escape
having to deal with large-scale you know
large-scale deterioration of our life
as we know it if we do not address
uh or if we do not mitigate address do
whatever we can
uh the the issues that we have on earth
i know this is a long
uh way of saying i'm not moving to mars
but uh you know i have it's just it's
surprising hearing you know because
someone who wants to obliterate the
kuiper belt
and destroy the oort cloud
maybe that's just a demonstration of
your awesome prowess
uh but i would have thought you know we
destroyed earth so at least and we have
some practice on earth
then we move out in the solar system go
to mars destroy that and then we go out
to the oort cloud and then finally we'll
learn how to take care of ourselves
uh we have a question from matt fox who
is the memes of destruction
on clubhouse he is asking to ask a
question we have
sh uh sharina rice and matthew
me leg i'm going to invite them up
they're going to ask you some quick
questions and then we're going to close
out the stream
so matthew go ahead you're on with
professor constantine petition of
caltech
thank you so much for doing this my
question is
based upon your experience what do you
think would be
the best model for what this could be
and the most likely model
for what we could be observing thank you
um i'm presuming presuming
matthew here is talking about the the
outer solar system
the planet nine is a planet yeah um
look i mean i think i think that both
the best model
and the most likely model here are are
kind of the same thing
uh i believe that what we're seeing are
the gravitational effects
of of a distant uh
you know five earth mass planet that
was being created together with you know
baby neptune and baby uranus and then
got
in sort of scattered out by jupiter and
saturn and had its orbit further
modified by some effects such as passing
stars
um and now we are seeing the kind of
long-term
billion-year accumulation of its
gravitational potential and
we're kind of seeing that as the uh as
the signature
um there are other explanations out
there
um i think that uh you know
they are you know not necessarily
completely
you know implausible they're just less
likely
last question clum house comes from
serena
hello this is sherina and my sister is
molina rice
she is in greg lawlin's lab at yale and
she's working with tess
to survey the whole sky to look for
planet nine looking at different speeds
which a planet can move
at different distances from the earth so
i'm wondering what other people's
perspectives are
on this kind of method to survey the
whole sky first planet nine
this is sharina and i am done speaking
all right so the uh if i understood the
question correctly the
uh the question was what other methods
are there
aside from tests uh to
to survey the entire sky um tess
is certainly all right and to give
context tess is a space mission
right which is looking predominantly
looking for
exoplanets but you know you can take
advantage
uh as uh as molina is doing of the fact
that the pixels are actually quite big
and you can shift and stack
uh to kind of increase your signal to
noise
that way so that's certainly one way to
do it the other way
to do it is ground-based and this is why
there are rubens is an exciting
advancement that's coming up
in the next few years where you just
point the telescope up in the sky
and you know start chopping uh start
collecting data and of course the earth
is nothing more than a spaceship that's
going around on
its trajectory uh if you will so you
know eventually you cover
a huge portion of the sky that way as
well
um there have been other um
there have been other near all sky
surveys
as well but in the visible spectrum
in which i think you know which is kind
of the best bet for for planet nine
um i think vera rubin is
a is a great bet but it would be so much
cooler
if just uh you know we just found it and
test data i mean that would be
that'd be really fun
so yeah i'm really really excited about
the work that
uh that they're doing with tess it's
it's really it's clever
and it's cool and uh you know
i like it i like it very good
okay everybody i want to thank uh
everybody for tuning in to the stream
and for joining us in clubhouse uh
please do subscribe on youtube dr brian
keating
if you have not already i have wonderful
guests coming up including sarah seeger
as i mentioned of mit
the rival beavers on the east coast uh
to caltech
and uh professor batigen's beavers on
the west coast
uh also a stephen pinker coming up i
have a conversation with david pogue
speaking about
climate change and the destruction of
planet earth he wrote a book how to
survive and prepare for climate change
which is a hopeful book and i urge
people to look into that and so stay
tuned we have
an amazing wonderful guest on the into
the impossible podcast i am your fearful
host during this time of pandemic
podcasting
signing off uh and thanking professor
constantine fedegen i hope you'll join
us again constantine it's really so much
fun to talk to you
thanks thanks man we're all in love with
your mind keep it up my friend
enjoy the weekend thank you everybody
until next time
signing off brian keating for the into
the impossible podcast good night
everybody
bye constantine thank you so much all
right thanks so much
we'll talk soon bye bye